all right today is national freezer pop
day
and there's a local beloved company that
celebrates this every day with joy so
let's welcome back kayla young love
founder of joy pop team studio hey
welcome back all right now
let's talk about joy pot because these
are not just you know your average basic
popsicles okay
national freezer pop day is is a day
where we can celebrate the joy and the
process right of these treats yep so
what makes them special okay so aside
from being locally made here in las
vegas
we use real simple ingredients quality
so we prioritize flavor over everything
quality ingredients no artificial dyes
preservatives flavors
and we source a lot locally so local
roaster coffee pops um
fruit from gilchrist orchard so yeah
you'll not try a pop like this for sure
now i'm i'm opening one right now and
this is dragon fruit i happen to love
this one myself um so this this holiday
was started because everybody adults
alike have that childlike popsicle love
right right so when you're at home in
your kitchen a great activity with your
kids is to make them totally because you
make them at home too right well we have
kids and so i brought popsicle molds we
do these ones at home with our kids this
shows um you know how we make the pops
in our kitchen okay we'll talk about how
what's the process like so you know once
you recipe formulate you basically mix
we mix batches of 500 to a thousand pops
our machine
equipment will freeze pops at negative
five in 20 minutes so we make over a
thousand pops a day in our kitchen that
is amazing and then you know if you want
to just start simple what's this guy
this is just something off amazon i mean
this is something easy for the kids um a
good recipe for popsicles is fresh fruit
a little bit of sugar maybe a little bit
of water okay okay so it's a fun
activity for the kids and for the adults
alike and for you guys what are the
flavors because this is what i love
about joy pot the flavors are just out
of this world and so unique so name a
few thank you yeah one of our top
sellers is milk and cookies you can see
here i call it our bake shop we in-house
bake a fresh salted chocolate chip
cookie in vanilla base we have a no
sugar added mango dragon fruit pineapple
chili lime some unique flavors and some
classic strawberry shortcake baked in
house so i love it and you guys cater
you deliver popsicles to your door
nothing sounds better than that honestly
and what's the website people can get
more information yes wwe
or find us on instagram at thejoypopco
thank you kayla thanks for having us
happy summer happy national freezer pop
day jillian awesome to you yeah those
looks